Speaker 1: Any time there is a massive news
story as monumental as the arrest of a former
president of the United States, you have your
main story and then you have sort of subsidiary
stories and then you have secondarily subsidiary
stories.
One of those secondarily subsidiary stories
that has caught the eye and ear of many of
you is what is going on with attorney Alan
Dershowitz and Trump's former personal attorney,
Michael Cohen.
Now, to give you the background on this, Michael
Cohen, friend of the show, good guy.
He used to be Trump's fixer.
He was directly involved in the Stormy Daniels
hush money payments.
He served prison time for his involvement
in those crimes, which now Trump is being
indicted for.
And Alan Dershowitz is a historically left
wing lawyer who has really started to become
a darling of the right, regularly appearing
on Fox News and Newsmax and Steve Bannon's
show as a defender of Trump legally.
And Dershowitz is always quick to say, Listen,
I voted against Trump and I look forward to
voting against him again.
But this is so unfair and that's so unfair
and he's being treated so unfairly.
The new thing and this is this is just unbelievable
stuff.
Dershowitz says he's going to sue Michael
Cohen.
Okay.
This started last week with Dershowitz on
Fox News.
I'm going to take you through the entire story.
Dershowitz on Fox News said Michael Cohen
tweeted that I was involved with underage
girls on Jeffrey Epstein's Island and now
Michael Cohen's going to be in trouble.
So this is the start of the story.
Here's Dershowitz on Fox.
Speaker 5: Stringing together two inapplicable
statutes and using Michael Cohen.
Let me tell you something about Michael Cohen.
He's not through with his problems.
He just tweeted about me saying because I
had attacked his credibility, that I was involved
with underage girls on Epstein's Island.
I'm about to sue him now for defamation.
As you know, the woman who falsely accused
me acknowledged that she may have made a mistake
in misidentifying me and I would normally
not sue somebody.
Speaker 1: For I'm just going to sue.
Usually I wouldn't, but I'm going to sue.
Speaker 5: Writing that kind of nonsense.
But this is Michael Cohen, who's about to
try to prevent Donald Trump from running for
president of the United States and.
Speaker 1: Singlehandedly.
Speaker 5: Sue him for defamation.
Not let him get away with that.
And when I see him, I won't be able to prove
his repeated lies because he can't refuse
to testify in a civil case.
So his problems are just beginning.
I'm going to make it a little easier for Joe
Tacopina to tattoo to.
Speaker 1: That, he said.
Joe Jakob Pina.
Speaker 5: Cross-examined him, although as
I've said before, any first year student could
win this case if the name wasn't Donald Trump
and if it wasn't in Manhattan, this case has
to get out of Manhattan.
All right.
Speaker 1: So there is Dershowitz saying he
will be suing Michael Cohen.
Then he appears on Alex Jones show.
And again, when we talk about the downfall
of Alan Dershowitz in a time past, Dershowitz
would never even consider appearing on the
program of someone like propagandist Alex
Jones.
It would just be wide.
No, of course, I'm not appearing on Alex Jones
show.
But here is Dershowitz almost pretending like
it's a normal show, saying he is indeed suing
Michael Cohen.
Speaker 5: Start over.
You're going to sue Michael Cohen.
Now, that's big news, really dollars for defamation.
And then the question that if he takes the
witness stand, he'll be asked.
You say you started telling the truth.
Are you just lying about Alan Dershowitz?
You know, he wasn't on Epstein's out.
You know, he's never had sex with an underage
girl.
You just got mad at him because he called
you a liar.
So you made up a story about him.
So you're still lying, right?
How is he going to get around that?
Speaker 1: Yeah.
So Dershowitz very soon will be really inconveniencing
Michael Cohen, I guess, and then again later
continuing to follow the threat of this story.
Dershowitz finishing the rounds by appearing
on Steve Bannon's program on Real America's
Voice.
And he says, you know, after I threatened
to sue Michael Cohen, Michael Cohen texted
me and said, I'll take the tweet down.
But Dershowitz doesn't care.
He's still going to sue if he.
Speaker 5: Apologized or took it down or would
you back off that or you going to go after
him hard on this?
Well, let me read you the email we just sent
to me, Alan.
As you know from our conversation on my podcast,
I have, as always, had had tremendous respect
and admiration for you as a constitutional
lawyer and scholar.
If you were angered at my tweet, why not just
have called me and expressed that to me?
I am happy to remove the tweet.
But similarly, I ask that you treat me with
the same respect that I treat you.
Feel free to call me at any time.
Well, he's willing to remove the tweet.
That's not enough, you know, when you throw.
Skunk into the jury room.
You can take the skunk out, but the smell
still remains.
He accused me of associating with a pedophile
on an island with young people.
It's just a total and complete and categorical
lie.
Speaker 1: Well, now, see, now I'm confused.
I my understanding was that Dershowitz was
saying is it's true.
He did associate with Epstein, but he simply
never did anything specific involving underage
girls.
Now, in any case, my prediction other than
Alan Dershowitz never recovers his reputation.
My prediction is that Alan Dershowitz doesn't
sue because if he were to sue Michael Cohen
for defamation, whatever the outcome would
be, Dershowitz would be subject to discovery
and examination.
And even if it's true that Dershowitz was
never involved with young, whatever you do,
I don't think Alan Dershowitz at this point
wants to have to answer questions under oath
about his relationship with Jeffrey Epstein.
So call me crazy.
I don't expect Dershowitz to sue.
I could be wrong.
I'm terrible at predictions.
We will follow it and we will see